we already know that Donald Trump is
spending way too much time just watching
TV at the White House but we've now
learned that the White House and Trump
specifically has been really shaken up
by Melissa McCarthy Sean Spicer parody
on Saturday Night Live this past weekend
now I didn't find the impression to
actually be that good and thought the
segment dragged a little bit but the
fact that it has so bothered Donald
Trump is something I can really get
behind you like the thing right Pat you
have you seem generally very positive on
it well I don't think the impression was
spot-on
but I thought the substance was great
there I mean it wasn't really that even
much of a parody because she was using
the exact same techniques that he was
using with the media yeah the press
conferences themselves are almost like
parodies and we know that Trump has
already been kind of displeased with
Sean Spicer since that first appearance
were Trump force Spicer to go out there
and blatantly lie about the size of the
inauguration crowd and we now have
learned that Trump really didn't like
how Melissa McCarthy impersonated Spicer
and that it has really made Trump
consider whether Spicer is a liability
and here's just this is the most amazing
part to me Trump is apparently mad that
Saturday Night Live chose a woman to
play Sean Spicer as this is a from from
Politico which wrote about this on
February 6th more than being lampooned
as a press secretary who makes up facts
it was Spicer's portrayal by a woman
that was most problematic in the
president's eyes according to sources
cloak the close to him later a trump
donor added Trump doesn't like his
people to look weak remember that Trump
told people that nobody has more respect
for women than she does and it's
fascinating that what reportedly angered
him the most about this is that a woman
played his male press secretary and if
there was any indication at how upset
Trump is about this when he's generally
upset he'll immediately go to Twitter
here he was actually completely silent
and that actually tells us maybe even
more about how bothered he is about this
here's what really is stunning to me if
you're going to be upset about your
press secretary being so terrible at his
job that Saturday Night Live
decides to parody him in this way
shouldn't you be upset about his lack of
skills rather than the fact that he's
being played by a woman well definitely
not given every single person that he's
hired I feel like he believes he doesn't
have a way to kind of undermine these
comedians and kind of the weight that
they've been holding throughout this
election has definitely got under his
skin it's very odd it is very very odd
that that's what he's focusing on and
Twitter instigators sent out a call to
Rosie O'Donnell a longtime foe of Donald
Trump saying you should play Steve
Bannon during an upcoming episode of
Saturday Night Live and as we talked
about on the bonus show Rosie O'Donnell
said she would actually do that yeah it
would be nice because Rosie O'Donnell is
of course Donald Trump's arch-nemesis
but I think how Steve Benham was
portrayed in the last episode of SNL was
perfect amulet he was a skeleton the
attitude from Trump if he wanted to
totally defuse this would be I'm happy
for Saturday Night Live I support
freedom of speech even if I don't agree
with the substance they're hiring great
actors and these impersonations are
great it would totally deflate the
entire thing instead of fueling the fire
which has now happened as we found out
that Trump was angry that his press
secretary who's a man was played by a
woman on a comedy show that now has gone
completely viral he is actually miss
handling and he could deflate the entire
thing if he reacted in a slightly
different way Warby Parker is offering a
free five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trial dot-com slash T DTS I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big corporation
that keep prices very high like $300 for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing